[Music]
so
[Music]
on 9th of march
2022
at
18 43 hours that is 6 43 p.m a
high-speed flying object was picked up
inside indian territory
by air defense operations center of
pakistan air force
from its initial course
the object
suddenly maneuvered towards pakistani
territory
and violated pakistan's airspace
ultimately
falling near miya chanu at 1850 yards
that is 6 50 pm
and when it fell it also damaged some
civilian property
thankfully
no loss or injury to
human life was caused
it is important to highlight
that flight path of this object
endangered many international and
domestic
passenger flights both
in indian and pakistani airspace
as well as human life and property on
ground
whatever caused this incident to happen
it is for the indians to explain
it nevertheless shows
their disregard for aviation safety
and
reflects very poorly
on their technological prowess
and procedural efficiency
the incident
could have resulted in a major aviation
disaster as well as civilian casualties
on ground
pakistan strongly protests this flagrant
violation
and cautions against recurrence of any
such incident in future